la butte montmartre est en émoi la place
du tertre en pleine effervescence la
mairie de paris a décidé de faire du
ménage parmi les peintres les
portraitistes les cafetiers et les
restaurateurs au fil des ans en effet
les places sont devenues chères
on est arrivé à une véritable saturation
un carré aux artistes va donc être créer
une réglementation très stricte va être
appliquée le reportage de gérard davet
une dizaine de cabaretier contre 460
peintre portraitiste quand les cafetiers
avance avec leur table les peintres
recul avec leur chevalet c'est la
guéguerre place du tertre pour quelques
décimètres carré de pavés zizanie entre
commerçants béotien et artistes pur pas
du tout c'est un conflit purement
commerciale il faut que chacun gagne sa
croûte et l'espace vital se mesurent
chichement ya sans doute trop de peintre
sur cette petite place sans compter les
touristes c'est donc un problème
complexe qui relève également du conseil
de paris droite majoritaire et gauche
s'opposent sur le projet de création
d'un carré d'artistes en ce lieu trois
parties en présence d'ong et tout
d'abord michel qu'ils vivent peintre
responsable d'artistes sans frontières
une assemblée qui compte 300 et personne
une concertation à 3 absolument
mais dans des conditions raisonnables
d'objectivité c'est à dire avec un
pourcentage
au moins du tiers de représentativité
des artistes un tiers de commerciaux un
tir de commerçants et riverains et un
tiers de pouvoirs publics que soit 2 des
impôts de la voiture de la mairie vous
même du ministère de la culture ce qui
me semble être important dans la sphère
quand ils me croisent ils à prendre un
quart d'heure parmi les pilleurs s'en
poser problème si le client arrive bon
ses programmes et sylvia est pas parti
qui n'atténue demi heure de plus c'est
une perte pour moi et pour tous les
autres commerçants
attends je répète et peint des portes de
douche il en faut il en faudra toujours
place du tertre
on accuse toujours les édiles municipaux
de choisir les commerçants contre les
peintres
on ne peut pas laisser dire une chose
pareille en effet en ce qui concerne la
place du tertre
il y a toujours eu concertation
concertation avec tous les organismes
représentatifs de la place du tertre
c'est à dire le collectif des artistes
peintres montmartre renouveau les
commerçants la préfecture de police et
la police locale
ah non marque le soir on déchante plus
qu'on ne chante